وتشهد العاصمه البريطانيه لندن مسيرات
للمطالبه بوقف فوري للحرب على قطاع غزه
وتاييدا للحقوق الفلسطينيه وقد قدرت
الشرطه عدد المشاركين حتى الان بنحو 100
الف ورفع المشاركون في المسيرات التي دعت
اليها عده منظمات من ابرزها تحالف اوقف
الحرب ولجنه التضامن مع فلسطين الاعلام
الفلسطينيه كما طالبوا بادخال معونات
عاجله الى القطاع ومحاسبه اسرائيل على ما
يقولون انها جرائم ارتكبتها في حربها على
القطاع معنا من لندن مراسل الجزيره اسد
الله الصاوي اسد الله لندن التي شهدت
سابقه وان شهدت من اكبر المظاهرات الداعمه
لفلسطين كيف تبدو مظاهره
اليوم نعم وسيله اليوم يمثل عوده للحراك
الشعبي المي للحقوق الفلسطينيه بعد توقف
دما ربما قربه الشهر في فتره الاعياد
الشرطه قدرت قبل نحو ساعه اعداد
المتظاهرين بنحو 100000 ولكن الاعداد الان
زادت اكثر كثيرا في هذا الاتجاه هناك بحر
من المتظاهرين في هذا الاتجاه هناك بحور
من المتظاهرين ساد س افسح المجال الان
الزميل المصور ليريكم الاعداد المشاركه في
هذه تظاهره وا يعني هذا البحر من الاعلام
الفلسطينيه الكثيره للغايه الموجوده في
وسط لندن المسيره مستمره يعني مر من من
جانبنا هنا منذ اكثر من ساعتين ربما هذه
الاعداد وما زالت الناس تتوافد المطالب
الرئيسيه هنا وسيله هي وقف اطلاق النار
فورا في قطاع غزه وال ادخال المساعدات
الى المدنيين في القطاع ورفع الحصار
المفروض على قطاع غزه بالاضافه الى وقف
قصف اليمن هناك مطالب وانتقادات كبيره
للحكومه البريطانيه والحكومه الامريكيه
بسبب قصف اليمن مؤخرا
وهناك نوع من التاييد الكبير والامتنان
الكبير ل حكومه جنوب افريقيا بسبب اقدامها
على مقاضاه اسرائيل على في عفوا في محكمه
العدل الدوليه هذه
الاعداد يعني لا يعني ليست موجوده هنا
كامر سهل يجب الاشاره وسيله الى ان درجه
الحراره هذا الصباح كانت سالب ثلاثه والان
درجه الحراره في هذا المكان هي صفر
وبالتالي يعني وجود متظاهرين كثر بهذه ال
طريقه في مثل هذه المظاهره ليس بالامر
الهين على الاطلاق اسد الله هل من شخصيات
بارزه تشارك في
هذه
المظاهره هناك عدد من الشخصيات البارزه
التي يتوقع ان تشارك في وقت لاحق عندما
يقام المسرح الرئيسي هناك مسرح اليوم بسبب
عدد المتظاهرين الكبير واحد في ميدان
البرلمان وواحد في ميدان تراف الجر كلاهما
في وسط لندن وبالتالي نتوقع اعداد كبيره
من المتحدثين على هذين المسرحين ولكن هناك
مشاركه لجهات عده يعني الموجودون ليسوا
فقط افرادا عاديين هناك مشاركه من قبل
نقابات متعدده من قبل تحالف اوقف الحرب
لجنه التضامن مع
فلسطين جمعيه اصدقاء الاقصى هناك مشاركه
لاتحادات عماليه ونقابات لجمعات تدافع عن
حقوق
الطواقم الصحيه مثلا هناك صور لاعضاء
الطواقم الصحيه الذين قتلوا في غزه ترفع
هنا في هذه المسيره بالاضافه الى وجود
دولي هذا او بعد دولي هذه المظاهره كما
يقول منظمون هي جزء من تحالف يقام يقيم
مظاهرات في نحو 30 دوله في ست قارات
بالتزامن في ذات اليوم في هنا في لندن وفي
مدن اخرى كثيره من العالم وبالتالي هم
يقولون انهم جزء من حركه تضامن عالميه
مؤيده للحقوق الفلسطينيه ومطالبه بوقف
فوري لاطلاق النار في قطاع غزه وبمحاولة